aquí tenemos una ecuación que tiene
algunas expresiones racionales en ella y
necesitamos encontrar las soluciones a
esta ecuación así que como siempre te
invito a que hagas una pausa trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta es decir deberías poder descubrir
qué valores de x satisfacen a esta
ecuación
muy bien vamos a hacerlo todos juntos y
bueno cuando cuando yo veo denominadores
en algunas ecuaciones digamos mi primera
estrategia casi siempre es manipular
estas expresiones para que ya no
aparezcan denominadores entonces como
sería cómo sería esto bueno pues del
lado izquierdo tenemos un factor x menos
1 así que lo que podemos hacer es
multiplicar de ambos lados por x menos 1
entonces del lado derecho multiplicamos
por x 1 y del lado izquierdo también
multiplicamos por x menos 1 muy bien
entonces también tenemos un denominador
x + 1 verdad del lado derecho así que lo
que podríamos hacer es multiplicar de
ambos lados por x + 1 entonces espero
que me quepa aquí tengo que multiplicar
de ambos lados por x + 1 y por supuesto
tenemos que multiplicar de ambos lados
para que no cambien los valores verdad
entonces veamos vamos vamos a tratar de
continuar
pues en este caso qué es lo que va a
ocurrir este factor x menos 1 se cancela
con este otro por supuesto que esto
siempre es válido para x distinto de 1
verdad para x distinto de uno de estos
dos factores se cancelan y veamos qué es
lo que nos queda del lado izquierdo
entonces vamos a tener x + 1 que
multiplica a este factor de aquí es
decir menos 2 x + 4 - 2 x + 4 y vamos a
ver qué es lo que ocurre del lado
derecho bueno lo que podemos ver aquí es
que estos dos factores van a multiplicar
a tres entre x más 1 entonces para este
primer término
estos factores x + 1 se cancelarían
verdad y entonces sólo tendríamos 3 que
multiplica a x menos 1
eso es 3 x menos 3 verdad simplemente
nos queda multiplicar 3 x
x 1 y además tenemos este término
digamos menos 1 que multiplica a estos
dos entonces tendríamos tendríamos menos
1 que multiplica a x menos 1 y que
multiplica después a x más 1 entonces en
realidad lo que nosotros podemos ver es
que este producto en realidad son
binomios conjugados verdad entonces
tendríamos una diferencia de cuadrados
verdad esto sería x cuadrada menos 1
verdad entonces déjenme cambiar esto que
había puesto por equis cuadrada menos 1
aquí dijimos que todo esto es x cuadrada
menos 1 entonces todo esto multiplica a
x cuadrada menos 1
x cuadrada menos uno entonces mejor lo
sigo en otra línea para no es tan rápido
muy bien entonces qué es lo que vamos a
poder hacer del lado izquierdo ahorita
vamos a hacer una vamos a usar la
propiedad distributiva del producto así
que vamos a multiplicar x x menos 2 x
esto nos da menos 2 x cuadrada x x 4 nos
da más 4x ahora multiplicamos 1 x menos
2 x y nos da menos 2x y 1 por 4 será 4
verdad más 4 y esto que será igual
bueno pues del lado derecho lo que
tenemos será 3x menos 3 3 x menos 3 y
ahora tenemos menos 1 por x cuadrada que
es menos x cuadrada y menos 1 x menos 1
es
una verdad entonces vamos a ver si
podemos simplificar un poco aquí tenemos
4 x menos 2 x todo esto simplemente será
2x entonces aquí tendríamos menos 3 + 1
verdad esto lo podremos simplemente
simplificar como menos 2 y vamos a
reescribir lo digamos con un color más
neutral aquí vamos a tener entonces
menos 2 x cuadrada más 12 x verdad desde
aquí más 4 y esto será igual a menos
menos equis cuadrada aquí lo tenemos
verdad poniendo primero lo que tiene
digamos la potencia digamos 2 aquí
tendríamos menos x cuadrada luego
tendríamos más 3x y luego tendríamos
menos 2 verdad entonces lo que vamos a
hacer y esto ya digamos lo hemos visto
varias veces en ecuaciones cuadráticas
es digamos igualar hacer que esta
expresión quede igualada a cero es decir
sumamos de ambos lados
digamos por ejemplo podríamos podríamos
sumar voy a hacerlo con un color morado
podríamos sumar x cuadrada para cancelar
de este lado pero tenemos que sumar x
cuadrada también de este lado podríamos
sumar menos 3 x de este lado y sumar
menos 3 x de este lado y sumar 2 del
lado derecho y también sumar 2 del lado
izquierdo entonces qué es lo que tenemos
del lado izquierdo del lado izquierdo
tenemos menos 2 x cuadrada más x
cuadrada esto es menos x cuadrada
tenemos 2 x menos 3 x esto es menos x y
4 2 son 6 y esto será igual a bueno pues
esto se cancela esto también y esto
también y nos queda todo esto igual a
cero verdad y como en realidad a mí no
me gusta poner aquí que no me gusta que
tenga el signo menos el término digamos
el principal el término con la potencia
2 pues podríamos multiplicar de ambos
lados por menos 1 verdad
multiplicar de ambos lados por menos 1 y
aquí lo que obtenemos es x cuadrada más
x menos 6 igual a 0 verdad entonces
ahora lo que podríamos hacer es tratar
de factorizar esta expresión así que
déjenme hacerlo de este lado derecho
tenemos la expresión x cuadrada más x
menos 6 y esta expresión la podemos
factorizar pensando en dos números que
multiplicados nos den menos 6 y sumados
nos den 1 entonces por ejemplo podemos
ver que más 3 y menos 2 funciona verdad
entonces sería x + 3
x2 es igual a 0 verifiquemos + 3 x menos
2 es menos 6 y 3 más menos 2 nos da una
verdad más 1 entonces esta factorización
es correcta y ahora si tenemos un
producto de dos números que nos da cero
pues algunos de ellos tienen que ser
cero entonces x + 3 es igual a 0 o bien
x menos 2 es igual a 0 en el primer caso
si red si restamos 3 de ambos lados
tendremos que x es menos 3 o del lado
derecho si tenemos que x menos 12 0
sumamos 2 de ambos lados y tenemos que x
es igual a 2 verdad entonces aquí
tenemos nuestras soluciones pero debemos
tener cuidado de que la ecuación
original no tenga términos indefinidos
verdad y para tener términos indefinidos
deberíamos digamos sería cuando
dividimos entre 0 verdad entonces aquí
para dividir entre 0 sería cuando x
a uno y aquí cuando dividí digamos para
dividir entre cero sería cuando x es
menos 1 que no es ninguno de estos dos
así que podemos estar muy seguros de que
estas dos soluciones son en realidad
soluciones de nuestra ecuación original
si digamos en cambio alguna de las
soluciones tentativas en definir algún
término de la ecuación entonces digamos
es decir estamos pensando cuando se
anula el denominador verdad entonces en
realidad serían soluciones de los pasos
intermedios que hemos desarrollado por
aquí pero no serían soluciones de la
ecuación original sin embargo este no es
el caso por lo que podemos estar
completamente seguros de que estas son
soluciones de la ecuación original